7 c'est le nombre de cas de grippe
signalés dans les hôpitaux français
depuis octobre 2020 c'est du jamais vu
pour cette période de l'année
normalement propice à l'épidémie de
grippe
l'année dernière à la même période des
dizaines de cas était déjà signalé aussi
bien dans les hôpitaux que dans la
médecine de ville
alors le virus de la grippe s'est il
réellement évaporée la réponse dans
facture les chiffres parlent d'eux-mêmes
l'épidémie de grippe sont quasi
inexistantes cette année en france
habituellement la maladie touche 2,5
millions de personnes et fait chaque
année son lot de victimes avec en
moyenne 10 mille morts par an selon le
dernier bulletin hebdomadaire publié par
santé publique france il n'y a pas de
circulation active des virus grippaux
il s'agit selon les experts d'un
phénomène rare et singulier mais qu'est
ce qui explique cet événement en réalité
trois choses premièrement ce sont les
gestes barrières et vous les connaissez
masque lavage de mains distanciation
deuxième élément le vaccin est le
dernier un peu plus surprenant il s'agit
du coc vide
les experts sont formels dans ce
contexte de crise sanitaire qui dure
depuis le printemps
l'application des gestes-barrières et la
vigilance des français ont grandement
aidé à faire reculer l'épidémie de
grippe saisonnière actuellement il y à
des mesures barrière très importantes
qui sont suivies et donc le virus de la
grippe se propage comme le lakovic 19
donc ça peut être un un empêchement
considérable
c'est une transmission par les
postillons par eux les sécrétions
respiratoires et les aérosols nadir dans
des atmosphères confinées
mais il il se transmet mme sy par les
mains sales c'est à dire que le virus
survit sur des supports et si vous avez
les mains sales vous pouvez transmettre
ses vrais pros coudre les virus
respiratoires
il comprit pas dans le virus
respiratoire syncitial qui donne des
bruits de fond
donc c'est exactement les mêmes modes de
transmission si les gestes barrière joue
un rôle essentiel dans la protection
contre l'épidémie de grippe
le vaccin y est aussi pour quelque chose
c'est la deuxième explication
ce n'est pas une nouveauté les français
font partie des citoyens du monde les
plus sceptiques vis-à-vis des vaccins
et pourtant il semblerait que la
pandémie de kobe de 19 l'heure et fait
prendre conscience de son importance
les français se sont littéralement
arraché les vaccins contre la grippe
jusqu'à créer des pénuries dans
certaines pharmacies et obligeant l'état
à débloquer son stock
vous êtes 13000 dans cette année à vous
êtes fait vacciner contre 10 millions
l'année dernière
il est certain que si la population est
bien immunisé à ce moment là le virus ne
peut pas circuler parce que les vacciner
contre le virus de la grippe en général
ne sont pas du tout contents ceux qui
peuvent constituer avoir la maladie font
une maladie bénigne qui tua ni ya pas de
forme grave chez les vaccinés en
d'autres termes tu adhères que si on est
vaccinés on peut être malade
mettons de 30 à 40% des cas mais avec
une maladie très bénigne et ce avec la
grippe c'est quand même maladie qui est
très invalidante
dans sa forme sans son immunité presles
cette augmentation de la vaccination
permet d'éviter en bon nombre de
contaminations notamment chez les
personnes les plus vulnérables comme les
personnes âgées
il faut noter que cette année dans les
ehpad 50 à 60% du personnel s'est fait
vacciner contre 20 à 30% d'ordinaire
limitant les risques de transmission
mais si finalement tout ça était dû au
prix de 19
c'est la troisième explication certains
experts sous la vie l'idée selon
laquelle vous serez face et une
interférence virale selon le catalogue
index des sites médicaux de langue
française
l'interférence virale est un phénomène
par lequel une infection par un premier
virus entraîne chez des cellules ou des
tissus une résistance à un second virus
en clair le coc u19 prendre est
tellement place dans notre système qu'il
n'y en aurait plus assez pour que le
virus de la grippe puisse se développer
patrick berche souligne que les
personnes atteintes par le col et 19 ont
moins de chances de contracter le virus
de la grippe bon c'est une possibilité
mais faut pas oublier que on a quand
même une faible proportion de la
population qui est affectée par l'aco
vide
de l'ordre de 20 % peut-être tout est un
peu plus actuellement c'est une des
explications sur le faible nombre de cas
de grippe même son absence de talent
actuelle peut-on pour autant parler de
disparition du virus de la grippe
pas tout à fait en effet les dates de
contagion ou de début d'épidémie varient
presque chaque année de même que sa
durée de 8 ha en semaine il arrive que
la grippe l'épidémie grippe saisonnière
commence en janvier seulement après un
coup de froid donc il faut être prudent
ça veut pas dire qu'elle ne va pas
arriver mais tout se passe comme si on a
vu des épidémies grippe qui commence un
peu plus tard donc il faut il faut être
prudent
la bonne nouvelle ce serait qu'on ait
pas d'épidémie trip cette année ce qui
ce qui serait étonnant parce qu'on en a
tous les ans depuis 1918 alors ce serait
étonnant que cette année en échappe on
peut avoir une épidémie très affaibli
donc ce qui compenserait beaucoup le les
dégâts dus de l'aco ville 19 selon son
type une guide france le pic de
l'épidémie survient dans la plupart du
temps fin décembre début janvier
mais selon le réseau sentinelles qui
surveille les données liées à l'épidémie
de grippe les pics épidémiques ont
énormément varié ces dernières années
par exemple en 2009 2010 le pic a été
atteint début décembre
né en 2016 il a été atteint presque
trois mois plus tard à la mi mars donc
si pour le moment le virus saisonnier ne
semble pas se répandre sur l'hexagone
on pourrait bien faire face à l'épidémie
de grippe d'ici quelques semaines
[Musique]